>>> ANYONE OUT HERE WATCHING
THIS NEW SHOW, HOUSE OF DRAGONS?
I AM THE BIGGEST GAME OF TLOENS
FAN.
I LOVE THEIR NEW SHOW.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, I LOVE
THEY'RE INCLUDING BLACK
CHARACTERS, BUT TO BE HONEST,
THE BLACK CHARACTERS TAKE ME OUT
OF IT A LITTLE BIT WITH THE STEP
BOND HAIR AND OLD TIME ACCENTS.
WHERE ARE THESE PEOPLE FROM?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
AND THEN THEY'RE COMING OUT WITH
SEASON TWO, I GUESS SOON.
AND SOMEHOW LAUREN MICHAELS
ARRANGED A SNEAK PEEK FOR HOUSE
OF DRAGONS TWO.
SO CHECK IT OUT.
>> BEFORE WE GO TO WAR WITH
KINGS LANDING, WE MUST KNOW WHO
OUR TRUE ALLIES ARE.
>> THESE REPRESENT ALL OUR PARTS
OF ALLIANCES, YOUR GRACE.
>> YES.
OUR NAMES ARE INSANE AND SOUND
IDENTICAL.
>> I'VE ALSO PREPARED A CHART OF
WHO'S HAVING SEX WITH WHOM.
>> LORD OF THE TIDES, THE SEA
SNAKE HIMSELF, CORLIF.
>> THIS IS A MOST WELCOME
SURPRISE.
WHERE HAVE YOU COME FROM?
>> THE MATRIX.
JUST KIDDING.
>> YOU MUST HAVE BEEN AT SEA A
LONG TIME THEN.
>> OF COURSE.
THIS IS WHERE MY PEOPLE ARE MOST
COMFORTABLE.
THE OCEAN.
WE ESPECIALLY LOVE BEING ON
SHIPS.
NEVER HAVE ANY CONCERN BEING ON
SHIPS OR WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN TO US
IF WE COME ON SHIPS.
>> DID YOU COME ALONE?
>> NO.
>> IT'S WONDER TO SEE YOU.
SINCE YOU KNOW JASON LUKE.
>> YES.
I LOOK AT MY FUTURE HUSBAND AND
KNOW HE'S GOING TO SATISFY ME
SEXUALLY.
>> TO WHAT DO WE OH THE HONOR OF
YOUR VISIT?
>> I KNOW YOU NEED SOME ALLIES
NOW THAT YOUR FATHER HAS DIED.
>> DIED?
THE DOCTOR SAID IT'S NOTHING.
JUST A LITTLE COUGH.
>> WELL, I FOUND YOU SOME NEW
ALLIES THAT HAVE COME TO PAY
THEIR RESPECTS TO THE TRUE
QUEEN.
>> WELL, WELL, WELL.
I HAVEN'T SEEN YOU IN A LONG
TIME.
HOW DOES IT FEEL TO HAVE SEX
WITH YOUR NIECE?
YUCK.
>> NO THANK YOU.
>> YOUR MAJESTY, LOOKS LIKE YOU
GOT A CASE OF THE MONKEY POX.
YOU GOING TO DIE IN THE MINUTE,
AIN'T YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> WELL, IF IT ISN'T OUR COUSIN,
LIGHT-SKINNED LARRY.
>> THAT'S ME.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE E.T. WHEN THEY
DRESS HIM UP FOR HALLOWEEN.
>> HEY, ALL THAT WAS HATEFUL,
MAN.
>> YOU'RE GETTING A LITTLE DRY.
>> THAT'S THAT DRAGON SPRAY.
>> MORE VISITORS APPROACH.
>> PARDON ME, GRACE.
BUT MY PENIS JUST FELL OFF.
>> BETTER SET SOME MONEY FOR
THAT.
>> WHO IS THIS FOUL MAN?
>> I CAME HERE FOR A DRAGON
ROCK.
I'M DOWN TO MY LAST 40.
MIND IF I GET A LIGHT?
>> BE GONE, ALL OF YOU!
>> OH, NO.
THERE'S MORE.
>> I'M ONE OF THE BADDEST
[ BLEEP ] YOU'VE EVER SEEN.
I HEARD YOU LIKE TO RIDE
WHISTLES, WANT TO RIDE MINE YOUR
FREAKING MAJESTY?
>> TAKE ME TO FLEE BOTTOM SO I
CAN CHECK ON MY HOLES.
>> I GOT A DRAGON NOW.
>> WHOA.
>> IT'S THE POLICE.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING ALL THE WAY
UP HERE?
NO MATTER HOW I FLY, THEY ALWAYS
FIND YOU, DON'T THEY?